hey your sleep paralysis monster is here
for a good time not a long time no hi my
name is Chris some people don't know now
you know your life is different now
welcome to a video which I try to
transform myself into something or
someone else and it usually goes pretty
mediocre and that's what we call
managing expectations I'm clean on the
outside if you can believe it this is
what a scrubbed up grace helbig looks
like anthropomorphize dirty sock i went
on instagram and i asked you guys
yesterday what kind of look should I
turn myself into and thank God some of
you said Crystal Method from RuPaul's
Drag Race the current season that's
happening right now
I believe the finale is actually this
Friday Saturday time doesn't is it I'd
have so glad you suggested that because
that's secretly what I wanted to do and
I was vetting you and you passed
only the couple of you that said that
and how perfectly the Crystal Method has
just uploaded on the drag race YouTube
channel a tutorial of her Freddy Krueger
look
[Music]
so that's what I'm gonna do today I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna take a second
I have to say this every time because I
feel like you won't believe me as you
watch this unfold but I'm really gonna
try my laundry it's just been real look
petty and needy I haven't watched this
tutorial yet so I don't know what I
should have picked up to be more
prepared story of my goddamn Quarantine
Lihue I'm nervous and excited and my
expectations are alright let's jump into
this or I can just keep talking and
prolong the inevitable that's also a
choice I can make
but I think the choice I'm going to make
is to finish up talking very soon and
actually begin to start all suicide no
you reserve the right to be I have
reserved the right to continue talking
before I start I'm team Crystal Method
this season of RuPaul's Drag Race
although I love all three I loved Jada I
loved Gigi
I love crystal crystal is I love
oddballs and weirdos and silly silly
human beings and she's all of that so
this is extra homage I don't want to do
her dirty and now we begin oh but
there's a Sargento cheese commercial
first great date night didn't change I
don't want to be a date night to Vinci
no I don't want to grill masters
commercial who do they think is watching
these it's gonna be yeah pretty easy so
watch me just like my digestive system
is pretty good at digesting Sargento
cheese she is starting out by gluing
down her eyebrows so I am I'm so good at
this already already deep this is a good
look okay I'm nervous I'm gonna get
hives that look like just tie-dye all
over my skin so that'll be cute
camouflage spider flight flight white
flight flight flight except now you
can't really flight you only have to
fight wow isn't that an interesting
philosophical thought that our body's
natural responses our fight-or-flight
but we can't even take flights now so
all we got to do is fight clean it up
and tweet it gluing them down she's
brushing through her eyebrows well use a
our dirty eyebrow brush
you know yeah this looks really good I
look like I just saw a fire and got
surprised oh she's got colored contacts
for this I do not so she put the gloves
on she's a quarantine queen okay so
she's covering her beard I don't think I
have to do that part okay so she
basically puts her foundation all over
her face so let's do that right now
I'm going to do my best look at this
oh-ho so how have you guys been doing
are your brains been on a scale of 1 to
I didn't even know I could have those
kind of thoughts were you guys that I'm
not mad about it
okay okay how's she contouring that's
insane contour look at that Wow
see shape what we see that we've made a
shape oh boy okay she blends up into
here goose has left the chat okay so far
been in my face look dirty do the thing
she licks her finger and then puts her
brows done every drag queen told me to
do it I had to do it it's worth it then
she puts a ton of setting powder am I
actually gonna do an okay job at this
one I don't want to toot my own horn too
quickly but you know I'm ready to honk
yeah oh we're only two minutes into a 20
minute tutorial Wow
she got some real aggressive highlight
going on Hey look your sleep paralysis
monsters having a difficult time
adjusting to the way the world is I just
need you to know I'm here to haunt you
but I got my own demons going on oneness
yeah we might have done a little
aggressive
Eliott be careful I'm doing a drag to
Tory honker okay she's contouring her
nose okay then she blends it with her
finger I were gonna do that Wow okay no
tinier pointy err bitchier let's move on
she puts red on the tip of her nose like
a clown nose do you like the little
clown nose oh look I look chilly or like
I'm done an extraordinary amount of
drugs okay blush dots look at that so
cute okay because everything was powder
I looked like I passed out in a bakery
she's using a white I think I'm gonna
try to use this white up and then down
feeling really good about this oh it's
working oh my god other side oh my god
this takes me back to when I was younger
and I got into clowning for one second
and my dad bought me a magic kit and I
named myself giggles the clown and it
performed on my little brother's
birthday party for our family and I got
paid $25 and then I never did it again
because I scared myself with my
entrepreneurialship okay now she does an
ivory up and over he gets really close
to the triangle Oh clown Klingon cute
that's good feels good feels good oh wow
cool before it's so big then she does
more dark contour on the edges look at
this beautiful Chewbacca
wow she's just throwing red on there now
she's doing her eyes with reds and
oranges which are great subtle colors
that are that are very easy to fix if
you happen to mess up at all whatsoever
I'm gonna use the red facepaint she's
just gone for it smashes on oh wow okay
she's doing just full red eyes all right
grungees now using her fingers to blend
in this red and make it look grungy and
messy oh yes it's allergy season y'all
so she's just smashing black around in
there now okay oh that feels great
very subtle Wow I feel great I feel like
that clown from it would be so corny
right now if it's all me mash this in a
little bit she said she wants it grungy
which is just a cool way I think to say
it's okay if you're not good at it all
of my content its grungy this is the
cooler way of saying it's a bit of a
master now a drawn brows she does some
texture in the front and she just drills
soon oh look at the texture oh that's
some eyebrow texture then she goes up
and over Wow
very hot Wow she's setting it with
powder I don't want to do that okay so
she's really doing powder snow I think I
should probably do some powder great
done oh and now she brushes it off okay
get off get off beautiful bronzer powder
across now and then she gets something
then she makes a line as you pulled it
up don't forget the neck then she does
it again with a darker color I'm just
gonna do it again with the same color
and pretend like I'm still participating
she does red shadow to try and blend
nice to blend these two layers so keep
it grungy now she's doing black shadow
all over her eye I'm gonna go see if I
have it I also have to pee I took a piss
and I saw myself in another mirror and I
would have scared the piss out of myself
if I you know didn't take a piss black
eyeshadow we have some now smash this
all over who all she takes liquid liner
and puts it over her eyebrows whoa fun
oh and she does her hair's with black
eyeshadow and she licks her brush before
she puts it in there okay I'm gonna
actually draw a line okay I use liquid
liner instead I think we get the same
effect putting really really hot pink on
her nose goes on nose okay it's time for
lips don't big ass black lips okay then
she connects them oh goodness
yep she's growing even bigger oh girl
okay a happier lift driver I've done
everything we do the bottom part Oh the
bottoms getting do me it's like her face
is having six different allergic
reactions all at the same time Oh
perfect oh my god okay oh she put some
pink shadow on the corners of the mouth
I'm getting slightly impatient because
this has been over an hour
oh and then she's a liquid liner to line
her lips Wow we've lined them oh my god
okay hold I got changer about it there's
still so many steps put white inside her
eyes so into your kit I have so much
respect not bad okay
litters I don't
very many glitter options in that I have
this one she uses three different kinds
of glitter I have one sort of glitter so
we're gonna do that and put it all over
the white ready cleans the line with the
liquid liner dip good enough oh and that
she does black glitter on the lips I
don't have black glitter for the lips
and that's like a big thing that she's
doing I'm gonna use this glitter that I
have on the lips and just see what
happens this might be the wrong move but
all of this is the right move because
nothing is wrong everything is fine he
get the same sort of effect I mean we
got the shiny lips oh so she's just
putting glitter everywhere so let's just
put glitter everywhere now no time to be
conservative glitter goes everywhere Oh
cute oh she's doing some highlighter
down the nose Wow
oh my god she's a little white dot on
her nose we did it oh my god we did it
doing lashes now do I got these lashes I
don't have lashes like her but I'm gonna
try and cut them so they look a little
bit like her
well she puts two on top and one on the
bottom I don't know about that okay
we'll try it these go on their eyelid
okay whoa all right I guess that's how
that's supposed to go mmm no no it feels
fun everything about this feels
incredibly normal so they're up in there
so she does lashes under her eyes to me
put lashes on under your eyes not like
that apparently okay we got lashes under
and now we just got to do the other
lashes closer to our eyes it's the most
amount of lashes I've ever put on myself
consciously I feel like at this point we
can do no wrong we're thriving pile it
on and we got those other lashes up Wow
okay then she applies some band-aids to
her face so we're gonna get some banding
she just puts band-aids all over at the
edge of your head hey there's a band-aid
does that work okay she finished her
look it's time for us to finish our look
[Music]
this is our finished Crystal Method
Freddy Krueger look I didn't have a
band-aid covered bald cap the way she
did so I kept the closest thing I had to
that which is my natural hair and I
think the look actually turned up pretty
good
we might be here - not having all the
glitter that she had and using what we
had and our limited actual skill sets as
a makeup artist I think we did an okay
job I honestly I feel sexy
can't say I felt that at all during
quarantine as of late so this really put
a pep in my vagina step how do you guys
think I did you've been sitting here the
whole time finally honking honk I feel
like Crystal Method I feel silly
standoffish creepy and confusing and
cute all at the same time thank you guys
for recommending a Crystal Method look
if you liked this video give it a thumbs
up I like this very much leave a comment
down below on what other looks you think
I should test out because we know I got
nothing but time and unrealistic belief
in my abilities cute thank you guys for
watching other than that I don't know
what you think
oh you it looks kind of attractive yeah
like a Halloween Horror Nights booth
babe oh cool I like it good job and just
like the Hat I think Emma yeah maybe
it's bad something is really working but
a lot of it's not you should be a judge
on RuPaul's Drag Race it's basically
everything they say all the time I don't
know what Freddy Krueger's
catchphrases Kreuger I barely know it we
gotta go we gotta go we gotta go